you know him you love him I present to
you the man defending his regular ship
on New Year's Eve this is the great Hans
Kim
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody thank you guys good to be here
um I love it when there's a conflict in
the Middle East cuz I get to find out
which of my friends I thought were
Mexican
[Music]
I shouldn't be flying
with I've been getting a lot of hate
online for my jokes about the Israel
Palestine conflict a lot of people
online have been calling me a Jew hater
which I hate cuz for a second there I
think they're calling me a
Jew Jew
no hater
okay
my girlfriend has recently been getting
on my ass you know she's like you got to
shave cuz when I kiss you it hurts when
you have a 5:00 shadow I'm like you
think that hurts try rubbing the tip of
your dick on your September o'clock
shadow thank you there he is exactly 60
seconds Hans Kim with another new minute
very exciting thank you it's very
new what' you say it's very new yeah
how' you feel like that went I felt like
that went better inside my head where I
was just inside my own head the Mexican
joke is killer because that is true
right you know you can never tell these
days it's it's
crazy it's
unsettling yeah those brownies those
brownies that's what I call them if you
don't know which ones they are yeah it's
crazy I uh I recently went to a Thai
restaurant and I thought they were Thai
turns out they're
Mexican
ah interesting yeah what did uh how was
the food the panti would tasted a little
bit a little bit
Mexican it's like a little sweet but the
the curry was great so I don't know what
it is with Mexicans and Curry but they
really got a way with curry these
Mexicans
okay well uh this is all very
interesting makes sense Mexicans and
Thai people both have a love for
rice and this is like a Nazi cooking
show like a white supremacist
cooking rice Mexicans
hi so uh Hans you're all over the news
this week I can't believe you didn't
really cover that oh yes you didn't talk
about that in your brand new minute you
forgot that for the first time ever in
your life you are in the world news yes
thank you
um it might be worth acknowledging I got
on the news for telling a joke that the
New York Post thought was off color so
you know that's a good sign I take that
as a compliment [__] New York
Post what they called him an idiot oh
the New York Post idiot comic oh wow and
there was no one in the article calling
me an idiot they just wanted to call me
an idiot so they put quotes yeah New
York Post quickly becoming TMZ while TMZ
is becoming more of a legitimate news
source it's kind of weird but TMZ
covered you this week too oh [__] I
didn't know you didn't know that I had
no idea okay and the Rolling Stone
covered you today did you know that yes
in Brazil yes oh it was the Brazilian
Rolling
Stone my team my council did not tell me
it was the Brazilian Rolling Stone thank
you MC Vader for you see Hans and the
Rolling Stone today no I didn't get a
chance to read the Brazilian Rolling
Stone you [__] goofballs who's on the
cover of a Brazilian Rolling
Stone just anybody that's oh the
Brazilian Rolling Stone funny enough
written by Tha people you never know
what you're going to get there's always
roll reversal Happening Here uh but it
was a Matthew Perry joke correct would
you like to do the joke that got you in
trouble see if we see if we can get you
in trouble again double Perry yeah
Matthew Perry Matthew Perry fat bloated
corpse Matthew Perry recently passed
away very sad uh you know for a guy on a
show called friends he could have used a
couple no that's not it you didn't even
do your own
show did not set it up right this is why
you are really an idiot comic honest
incredible it's Matthew Perry drowned in
a hot tub for a guy that was on friends
you think he would have a couple of
them really not worth canceling any went
over definitely
not the only person that ended up
canceled in the whole thing was Matthew
Perry you survived with your head above
water yes I mean the New York
Post
Yeah the New York Post made Matthew
Perry's life miserable when he was alive
I'm just talking about him when he's
dead that's a really good point yeah wow
who cares if you're dead you can say
anything like [__] Bob Barker
whoaa wait a minute beloved Bob Barker
Triple B has been brought into the field
this play is under review how dare you
talk about the unbelievably cool the
band that was there with us on all of
our sick days as a child you went
straight for Bob
Barker I was normally when a korean's
roasting a barker they're about to eat a
dog oh
thank you thank you oh that wasn't D's
okay oh that was the Price Is Right
theme on piano everybody red ban over
here yeah you got it oh8 bit that's
always good no don't don't don't Hans
anything else exciting happened this
week my girlfriend and I got into a huge
argument let's talk about that
she she wants me to come over all the
time she very rarely makes a drive over
to see me um and I you know I got really
mad at her I was like you're taking away
my time I really want to podcast you're
not letting me podcast um and that
really is hurting my comedy career I'm
getting mentioned in Brazilian Rolling
Stone so what did she say to that she
was like okay I'll do more of what you
want and uh today I jerked off on her
wow you love jerking off on her this is
incredible so when you're jerking off on
her is she fully clothed
she a thing like it seems like she's not
contributing at all to this is she awake
when it's happening or she kind of it's
better when she's not yeah uh h no she's
fully awake and consenting uhhuh is she
clothed I can't picture she starts out
clothes and then she does one of these
where she like lifts it above her tits
and that's where you that's where I
ejaculate on oh my god wow you're
basically just a one man she does the B
crer move
she she's like on the machine and you're
just
[Music]
hot
got and that's how it goes so then what
do you get her like a towel or something
like that what do you have like one of
those [__] little wet naps or
something I yeah I have a little towet I
got and then I wipe it off but at her
house I just used toilet paper oh God
amazing this is you ladies are really
missing out letting Hans Kim be out
there taken on the market I'm sure this
is what everybody wants is little bits
of toilet paper in their belly button I
mean what an opportunity of a Life
Time absolutely incredible double ply
yes the finest sh okay very good
absolutely the Quilted picker
uper all right well um uh Hans way to
get the show started you did it again we
love you that's hansam everybody we're
going to get through tonight's episode
we're pre picking another name the
bucket of Des